i just want to say that i'm shocked and
appalled and deeply saddened by the loss
of life but at sea in the in the channel
um i think that the the details are
still coming in but
uh
more than 20 people have have lost their
lives as as as you know and my my
thoughts and sympathies are first of all
with the the victims and their families
and uh it's an appalling thing
that they have they have suffered but i
also want to say that this disaster
underscores how dangerous it is to cross
the channel in this way and it also
shows how vital it is that we now step
up our efforts to break
the business model of the gangsters who
are sending people to sea uh in this way
and that's why it's so important that we
accelerate if we possibly can all the
measures contained in our borders and
nationalities bills so that we
distinguish between people who come here
legally and people who come here
illegally
but we also
use every
power that we can we leave no stone
unturned to
demolish the the business proposition of
the human traffickers and the and the
gangsters and
of course we have to work
uh with our french friends with our with
our european partners and i i say to
our partners across the channel now is
the time for us all to step up to work
together to do everything we can to
break these gangs who are literally
getting away with murder you've known
for some time that a tragedy like this
was a possibility
but the measures you've taken haven't
stopped the boats crossing the channel
does this show in the saddest possible
way that your plan isn't working what
this shows is that the gangs who
are sending people to see these
dangerous craft will will literally stop
it nothing but what i'm afraid it also
shows is that
the operation that's been conducted by
our friends on the on the beaches
supported as you know with uh 54 million
pounds from the from the uk to to help
patrol the beaches all the technical
support that we've been given we've been
giving they haven't been enough our
offer
is to uh increase
our support but also to to uh to work
together uh with our partners uh on the
the beach is concerned on the
the the uh the landing the launching
grounds for for these boats and that's
something i hope that uh will be
acceptable now in view of what has
happened because there is no doubt at
all that the the
the gangs concerned unless they are
shown that their business model won't
work that they can't certainly get
people over the channel to front over
the channel from france to the uk they
will continue uh to deceive people uh to
put people's lives at risk and as i say
to get away with with murder
you mentioned there about working
together um and it being
acceptable now things being acceptable
now that implies there were some
measures that weren't acceptable before
what are they what's changing well we
we've
we've had uh
difficulties persuading some of our
partners uh particularly the french to
to to do things in in in a way that we
think is uh the situation deserves but
and i understand the difficulties in all
countries
that all countries face but what we want
now is uh to do more together and that's
the offer that we're making thank you
very much can i ask one more please
sorry do you have full confidence in the
home secretary of course thank